something like that
hi my name is Brad Snyder I'm a
Paralympic swimmer my favorite movies
are the Star Wars movies if I had to
pick one I would say Empire Strikes Back
in September of 2011 I was a service
member in Afghanistan as part of a Navy
platoon working with Afghan Special
Forces trying to battle the Taliban
there in Kandahar unfortunately I
stepped on an improvised explosive
device buried in the ground and as a
result of the blast I lost my vision I
was really fortunate to come away alive
and largely unharmed but on the damage
to my face was irreparable and been
about three or four years since then and
this year was the first year we all went
back to the theater and watched Star
Wars as a family
it's been a fun thing for my family to
sit down and describe what does Harrison
Ford Han Solo look like now yo Han Solo
I used to be so I can really connect to
that film in a unique way the Star Wars
series being something that grounds me
to when I used to have my vision like I
don't know what Jennifer Lawrence looks
like she came to prominence after I lost
my vision so that you know she's a she's
a blank canvas for me
however Harrison Ford and Carrie Fisher
are people that I remember so like I can
really vividly imagine those characters
all of us have had to go through some
really tragic instances and really
evaluate who we are and find the good in
the situations that we find ourselves in
and and be resilient and continue to
move forward and I think that definitely
is something that's portrayed on screen
with specifically the character of Luke
Skywalker
what's cool about the forest is the
force is just kind of a it's a fictional
term for the intangibles around us right
there's so many things going on that we
may control or we may not control and in
the Paralympic world for sure when
you're standing behind the blocks in
front of 18,000 people and there's this
really big event and the finals and the
adrenaline and all these different
things going on you know there's a lot
of intangible forces around you and you
have to find a way to negotiate those
forces and you know execute a good race
I wouldn't proclaim Jedi swimmer maybe
I'm trying to become one